The United Kingdom is a parliamentary democracy.
Government is voted into power by the people...
...to act in their interests.
UK is also a constitutional monarchy,...
...although Queen Elizabeth II has limited powers...
...and is politically impartial.
Parliament itself is divided into two houses.
The House of Commons and the House of Lords.
Both make laws, scrutinize government and debate current issues.
The two-chamber system is designed...
...to act as a check and balance for both houses.
The countdown to a British general election...
...starts with the prime minister paying a ceremonial visit to the Queen...
...to formalize the dissolution of Parliament.
This used to be a constitutional recess tea,...
...but is now purely a courtesy call...
...following the introduction of fixed-term parliaments in 2011.
A political party that wins an overall majority in the House of Commons...
...with 326 seats or more at a general election forms the new government...
...and its leader becomes prime minister.
If there's no clear winner,...
...one of the two biggest parties, Conservatives or Labour,...
...could make a formal deal with a smaller party or parties,...
...such as the Liberal Democrats or the Eurosceptic UKIP Party.